thank you
good afternoon and welcome to this press
conference following the informal EU
defense ministers meeting higher
representative Jose pohel and the
Swedish Minister of Defense Paul Johnson
will debrief you on the discussions held
today we will then move to your
questions
so without further Ado High
representative you have the floor well
thank you and good afternoon to
everybody
first of all once again dear Minister
the ajan thank you for organizing this
bold organizing this informal meeting of
the defense ministers
the defense minister was
devoted to Ukraine mainly
it couldn't be otherwise
we had Ukrainian minister of defense
who updated us on the military situation
on the ground
and explain which are the Ukraine's
military needs
and we know after listening to minister
lesnikov
that the next weeks and months but
mainly weeks we are talking about weeks
will be critical
because the military situation in the
ground remains very difficult
in particular in bad mood where they
Face Fight Continues
then we went to analyze what we are
doing to support Ukraine and what we can
do more
by the end of this month
our military assistant Mission will have
trained more than 11 000 Ukrainian
soldiers
and by the end of the year we expect to
have trained 30 000 soldiers
and all members spread the state
expressed their satisfaction about the
results achieved by this trending
mission
and committed to do more especially when
the battle tanks are arriving to Ukraine
and the crews of these battle times has
to be trained not only individually for
every tank but in order for all of them
to be able to fight
together
this will take our
training Mission Bay busy they are very
busy
and this training mission is another
proof of our own shaken and determined
support to continue
together with Ukraine
this is a key message that you would
like
to send to you
to send to the public opinion
after this meeting
after listening to minister radnikov
I think that there is a clear message
to be the best you could need to win the
war
and Ukrainian Armed Forces needs our
continuing support in particular
and this was the call I discussed you
today on artillery ammunition
it was also the message that we have
heard from president zelensky some days
ago I do being a Union Council
I know that I use of essence
we need to deliver more but we need to
deliver faster
and for doing that
I propose that
have an approach
which is based in three tracks
which are complementary one goes with
the others they cannot be considered
isolated it's not one yet but the others
know
the three tracks goes together
first we need a new support package
through the European fish facility
we need a new support package for the
reimbursement of the immediate delivery
of ammunition
that has to come from the national
stocks already existing or
pending orders work in process
any diet
made to standard for Savage standard 155
millimeters or 152 millimeters
and for this support package
I propose to the ministers 1 billion
euros from the European peace facility
second we need a coordinated demand
in order to procure 155 ammunition
once again through the European Defense
Agency I insisted on the idea that we
need to go in a coordinated manner
to address the industry an overall
package of demand
adding
the demand of the member states to
refill their stocks and also to provide
more for Ukraine
European Defense Agency
that was created by the Lisbon treaty
and is in charge of doing this kind of
things
common procurement has set out a project
for this purpose
and they can use a fast track procedure
to do it quicker
here we go together
we can reduce not only unit prices
but also we can reduce the delivery time
and European peace facility
can support these efforts
for the benefit of Ukraine
and I propose to mobilize another
billion euros for this second track
and the third track as I said is
complementary
we need to increase the European Defense
industry capacity to meet a massive
demand from our armies
not only for Ukraine
is for our armies
our armies provide part of their stocks
to Ukraine
is because they expect to be able to
refill these stocks thanks to a bigger
stronger capacity of our defense
industry
and for that we need to support
a ramp up of our manufacturing
capacities
and to reduce the production time we are
in war times
and we had to have a story to say a warm
mentality
I would prefer to talk about peace
I will prefer very much to talk about
these negotiations but unhappily I have
to talk about the Munitions because the
war continues raising
and that's what we have to do today
keeping the door open at any moment for
any kind of tick of talk or peace
negotiations
but today we have been talking about
reducing time and decreasing cost of
ammunition deliveries
these retracts are mutually reinforcing
and need to be conducted in parallel
there is a continuity between these
three tracks
your member states are encouraged to dig
further in their stocks
if they receive the guarantee that they
can replenish their stocks
because they reveal defense industry
will ramp up its capacities then they
will be more ready to support Ukraine
we had discussing about that
I think I can say it has been a general
agreement on this procedure
but they are
question spending
everything has to be discussed in detail
everyone agreed on the urgency to move
because everybody agrees on the
objective which is to support Ukraine
as much as possible and as quickly as
possible
and with the support of the Swedish
presidency we will continue reaching out
an agreement on a package deal at the
next job meeting which is as soon as the
next 20th of March
where the Ministers of Foreign Affairs
and the Ministers of Defense
will I hope reach a concrete and formal
decision on that to summarize
three drugs two billion users to provide
quicker
Munitions for the Ukraine to support
they are Miss and resist under Russian
invasion
then we had a work in London with the
NATO Secretary General stoltenberg and
the United Nations
under Secretary General for operations
Champion Lacroix and we'll discuss about
foray manipulation and interference
we have been
Gathering clear evidence of Russia's
information manipulation
in the threat report on foreign
information manipulation and
interference that we published in the
last 8th of February
and our preparation with United Nations
and NATO
has to increase in order to fight with
these new threats
because the fight is today not only on
the ground conquering land is also
Conquering the mind of the people public
opinions matters and public opinions are
being receiving a lot of this
information
in many of our partner countries
last word because today is the
international women's day
women's are key for the resilience and
the stability of our societies
they are for the rarely recognized but
this is the way to do so
this is a way to recognize how important
a woman's for their well-being of our
societies and for our resilience and
stability
in Ukraine and all around the world
womans are also soldiers
who in our peacekeepers
judges and human rights Defenders
we will continue to see their rights
being challenged
and European union and its member stage
fight against that
yesterday you adopted a package of
sanctions of nine individuals and three
entities
for their role in committing serious
human rights violation and abuses
particularly sexual and gender-based
violence
this represents a broad approach to
what's happening in the in the world
it covers two Taliban ministers
it covers the police in Moscow
it covers the militias in South Sudan
in Myanmar
Indian
everywhere
where's violation with the human rights
of the women's in particular has been
affected we have been taking a list of
sanctions
I repeat
that even ministers High location and
the minister for the preparation of
virtue and prevention of Vice
group police station responsible for
arbitrary arrests
high-ranked members of the Russian Armed
Forces
systematically participated in Acts of
sexual and gender-based violence in
Ukraine
the commanders of the South Sudanese
militias
responsible for the widespread and
systematic use of sexual and
gender-based violence as a war tactic in
the country
the deputy minister of former virgin
Mayan Martin
prison in Iran the Syrian Republic
guards
and the office of the chief of military
security Affairs in Burna all of them
are being sanctioned in view or their
roles
in gender-based human rights violations
on their sexual and gender dimension
but
I think
thank you
[Applause]
derivative here Joseph thank you very
much for your statement I would
especially like to join you in your
recognition of the efforts of the women
fighting in the battlefield and
Elsewhere for European Security in
Ukraine Sweden is fully committed to
your important work on genre quality and
together with the es World promote
gender equality within the full spectrum
of eu's Crisis management operations
Sweden has together with several other
member states being part of a pioneering
gender equality and gender perspective
within the defense policy and military
operations today we work with the even
member states in mainstreaming gender
equality throughout both civilian and
military csdp actions the importance of
women peace and security Again by ndcsp
is also highlighted in the city compass
for Sweden gender equality in the armed
forces is a question of credibility and
making sure that our defense
organizations reflect the society that
we protect that may also once again
welcome into Stockholm and I think we
had a very productive meeting uh this
morning and with a particular Focus also
on the continuing the EU support for
Ukraine support for Ukraine is of course
an overarching priority for the Swedish
government paid nationally based on a
bilateral basis or being internationally
the Swedish presidency will work to
ensure that the EU continues to deliver
on the needs of the Ukrainian Armed
Forces we would ever particularly glad
to have minister rasnikov with us this
morning
during our morning meeting the Ukrainian
people is fighting for their survival
but at the same time also for European
security our freedom and our values
we're also glad to welcome Lieutenant
General Andreas Marlo and Major General
Pizza direct from the German and polish
centers of the umam Ukraine in today's
meetings remarks I have remarkable
efforts are made by all by by the
ukrainians and we have the privilege to
provide training unfortunately more
troops needs to be trained as the war
goes on therefore it's Paramount
importance that we understand the
Ukrainian needs so we can adopt our
training and provide support in in
accordance to that needs the Swedish
presidency welcomes the proposal put
forward by Estonia and the external
Excellence service we will move rapidly
to address Ukraine's need for ammunition
and I think here the key is speed is of
the essence we therefore fully support
the efforts made by the European Defense
Agency to put up joint procurements the
Eda has a prominent role in the work at
member states could support and also
have a complimentary role to a
coordinating making is that the the Eda
which the role of the day would be
absolutely crucial
as the higher absence said we also had a
working launch together with our
partners with the secretary gentle
stolenberry and also the under secretary
for peace operations Champaign I think
it's very important also that we work on
creating stronger partnership between
the EU and NATO who are very glad with
the new EU NATO declaration that was
adopted in January and it's also very
important that the EU and the um Works
especially when it comes to operations
and we now stand ready to take any
questions that you might have
I guess
if I understood things correctly
take the micro okay
both the Eda and the countries are
supposed to try to ramp up the
production of the
itineraries early in the grenades
uh isn't there a reason for both EGA and
characteristics simultaneously try to do
this that is sort of uh
could you
we cannot hear you well so if you can
repeat the question slowly okay isn't
there a risk that if both Eda the
European Defense Agency and the
countries simultaneously try to ramp up
production uh of artilleries uh that
they sort of core instead of coordinate
there's a risk over the uh that the
birds try to tap the same sources so to
speak you know when they both go into
the system
uh if I understood well if she
understood well you say that to me so
you wonder if there is a risk
a risk of what
if they don't you've proposed e day
should coordinate this if the country is
simultaneously also try to ramp up
production
the risk of their approach the same
industries that they sort of have the
same sources there's not a coordination
then
look as I said maybe you haven't
explained myself well
there is three pillars because there is
a continuity
if I am asking a member state to provide
part of their ammunition stockpile to
Ukraine
and now this is the first part
remember I said will not be value to do
that if they are not convinced that they
could refill
their stocks in order to refill their
stocks we have to make our industry to
be more able to produce
the first thing for the industry to be
ready to produce more is to have a clear
signal of demand
which is the level of demand
the level of demand would be
determined by the common procurement
not only but the second pillar will send
a clear signal to the to the industry
that yes they have to increase their
capacity because there is let's say a
potential demand that
comes up not only for the member said
apart for your brain under Serbia which
is in the medium term is to increase the
capacity
so I don't see the risk by the country
is a matter of giving insurance
to eliminating the risk
the more the three pillars goes together
the less risky is for a member state to
be deprived of their stock of ammunition
because they will be sure whether the
industry will be able to refill the
stock
so the three pillars it's a matter of
dismissing the risk
if I may I I totally agree with the high
representative because the role of the
Eda is to coordinate to make sure that
that we do what that they are aware
what's still happening in the in various
capitals so the coordinating role of DDA
is something that we fully support and
we think that's going to be crucial in
order for for Europe to be able to
provide more ammunition to Ukraine
uh Andrew goodie from Reuters um a
representative on the on the second
pillar how quickly could that go so how
quickly could contracts be signed uh
joint procurement contracts be signed I
quickly could ammunition that comes as a
result of that second pillar be in
Ukraine and be used in the battlefield
and a related question if uh member
states follow your proposal that will
mean 2 billion from the European peace
facility used just for ammunition which
means the new ceiling that you've set
would be reached already does that mean
you will be asking for a further Top-Up
of the European peace facility Well as
you go to the second part of your
question which is the the one I could
answer better
because I am I don't have a crystal ball
certainly we decided at a part of two
billions
if we use this top up of two billions
for ammunition to Ukraine through two
procedures I understand now they are
cleared into procedures the two line of
working that certainly a memory stage
wants to continue using the European
peace facility they will have to go for
another
but this was not the issue of today
don't mix things because if you put
everything then at the end you decide
nothing today the issue was what do we
do with the two billion that we have
already decided
and you want to do more then you will
decide for more
certainly if you want to do more you
will have to decide for more but this is
a high level political decision that
belongs to the leaders at the European
Union Council on the 23rd of March they
will have to decide which is the level
of Engagement that they want to continue
having not only for UK but for other
accomplish in the world in which we are
engaged
how long does it take the the second
track well I'm sorry I don't have a
crystal ball but I know the procedure
member states who are willing to
participate they have to agree on the
terms of the procedure once we decide
the total amount
then it's a negotiation between the 15
European firms that are able to produce
this kind of Weaponry in order to fix a
price and time delivery according with
the account the amount that we request
and then once the Williams being rich
they will start producing
it's not going to be
short
but the sooner we start the better and I
don't know any other procedure that can
go quicker than this one
so I hope that by the end of the month
we can arrange with member states who
are willing to participate and this
procedure is not the only one possible
there are other possibilities I am not
excluding the member states will would
like to follow others on their own but
if we want to go all together with a big
package that includes not only the needs
of the member state but also the needs
of Ukraine and I am convinced that it is
the best way of doing that putting
together the expertise of the European
Defense Agency and the expertise of the
agencies of the national armies these
are pan-european purpose that has to be
solved and implemented with a bunny
rupian state
defense agency was created for doing
this kind of things they have been
working on the last six months to
prepare this program let's put into
practice
foreign
work for Swedish television tv4
given what we have heard from Ukraine
that they lack ammunition they're even
losing ground because of that how fast
can the first
rounds of artillery ammunition be
delivered given what we have heard here
that you you have told us yourself
first
don't believe that we haven't been
providing a munition
before today
is nothing new
since the beginning of the war we have
been providing ammunition to Ukraine
I can give you a figure European peace
facility
has reimbursed to member states about
450 million euros
for ammunition provided to Ukraine so
don't believe that everything is new and
until now nobody was providing
ammunition to your brain yes we had to
started doing that since the beginning
logically
the issue that today the war has become
a position war with an artillery fight
and is very consuming from the point of
view of the number of shots that
everyone is shutting against the other
before that the war was a moving wall
with less consumption of our Theory
today there is a high intensity war with
a lot of shots tens of thousands every
day
so the needs are bigger we have been
providing but we have to accelerate the
Rhythm every day there is a munition
coming from the European Union member
states arriving to Ukraine every day it
is a flow going on
the issue is it has to increase
and that's why we are trying to push for
more and quicker but the flow has been
flowing since the beginning
450 million euros for an ammunition so
when I'm proposing 1 000 million more
it's just double what we have already
done
okay figure it's something quite useful
thanks to everybody I'm here I have a
one question is whether the first
question is whether after this meeting
you have a better sense whether there
are enough demolitions in Europe and for
this one billion coming from IPS or
whether it is 1 billion in order to
provide these ammunitions very quickly
to Ukraine we also have to be used to
buy ammunitions outside you
second question is on these reports to
build New York Times I understand that
you say we wait for the final
investigation I understand that okay
you say no string
the second person whether you are afraid
of the potential impact this kind of
stories could have on public opinion in
the moment when there is this actual
push
or you talk about this Monumental was
talking about the war economy you are
also using the similar language so the
union is to change gear to do even more
but in the moment when there are these
kind of reports so I wonder a second
question is whether you are afraid of
the impact these reports could have in
key countries like Germany thank you
yes
I am asking to my Swedish colleague to
help look look
it's clear that we would prefer the
European Defense industry to produce the
ammunition that we need
because we need an European Defense
industry we need the capacity to produce
by yourself
and we don't have enough capacity
because we were used to live in peace
and the war was something that was not
in our imagination
but today in our industrial structure
the defense industry has to develop more
and certainly we will be asking
our firms to produce and our firms will
produce if we ask them and provide them
with a clear Horizon
of which is the level of demand as any
other producer
if I am asking someone to produce more
Tomatoes it will tell me how many and
for how long
well how many and for how long is the
question that I would have to give to
the answers so priority to the industry
certainly some member states has been
very clear on that
we wanted to pay money to be used
to create jobs in the European Defense
industry
and we agree on that
and we will try to do it as much as we
can but if tomorrow member state
provides ammunition to Ukraine taking
this ammunition from their stockpile I
am not going to ask him where did you
buy it
I'm not going to ask you where did you
buy it but for the second pillar for the
second track when we go to the market
and we ask the firms to produce we will
address us to the 15 European firm that
could do it
we don't need to go to look after
and look about the Nordstrom these are
serious things
very much serious things first
never be afraid of the truth
I am not afraid of the truth
any truth
but we are talking about by the time
being
speculations
investigations on the exact
circumstances are still ongoing in
Sweden maybe you can say something about
it the administer on Denmark and in
Germany
and let's be serious as long as
investigations are ongoing we cannot
draft
draw definitive conclusion what can I
say
I have to wait for having a clear
understanding of what has happening
it has been a sabotaged in the north
stream gas pipeline yet it has been it's
clear
it means one thing we have to be much
more vigilant
about the resilience of our critical
infrastructure because what has happened
with the north stream too may happen
tomorrow with a
cable of optic fiber or an electric
cable Supply electricity from one
country to another below the sea
and we have already taken straight
action to accelerate the work of
protecting our critical infrastructure
the resilience from Priority areas
and to give an answer to a response to
the international threats through
International cooperation in particular
with NATO but about what has happened
with the north stream too I don't know
and as far as the one that could know
and Germany authorities
I will not take any position
foreign
by a prosecutor and then being conducted
in support by the school district
security service and as long as that
process is ongoing I don't want to jump
into any kind of conclusions about the
attribution so I want to wait until the
inquiry is finished but I certainly
concur with high representatives of the
importance in general of supporting
critical infrastructure I think there's
an increased awareness of that also in
light of facts of hybrid threats being
something we have to increasingly being
challenged and exposed to as well and
that also goes down to our
infrastructure on various seabeds and
there's various initiatives in different
organizations on how to improve critical
infrastructure
thank you very much this ends our press
conference today thank you to the
interpreters thank you ministers and
thank you to this impeccable
organization thanks
thank you
foreign
[Music]